[Música]
olá boa noite
bom como ele disse eu trabalho com dor
há 26 anos há 26 anos o meu trabalho é
aliviar dor a dor cirúrgica passando
pela dor do câncer até a dor de cotovelo
alguém aqui já sentiu alguma dor
olha se dividir a dor em dois tipos a
dor aguda que é uma dor que exige uma
atitude imediata se não a gente corre o
risco de perder a vida ea dor crônica
que a dor que nós vamos conversar hoje
que é uma dor que não implica no risco
de morte iminente
mas p a longo prazo traz um prejuízo
muito grande de vida e por causa disso a
gente muitas vezes não entendendo a sua
gravidade se limita a tomar um
analgésico e tomar um analgésico pode
ser um pouco perigoso
então no meu consultório após me formar
eu recebia pessoas com queixas dolorosas
e o meu trabalho era quantificar essa
dor analisar de que tamanho lançador e
estabelecer tratamentos tratamentos
previamente programados previamente
protocolados e eu estava bem feliz no
meu papel de prescrever remédios ou
bloqueios o procedimento do operador
porque a dor é um sentimento muito
desagradável
porém nesse trabalho muitas vezes esse
paciente tinha que conviver com efeitos
colaterais desagradáveis com toxicidade
desses remédios
ele tinha uma dependência muito grande
de mim a sua qualidade de vida ea caindo
ea a vida ia ficando complicada mas a
vida continuava eu me sentia um papel
relativamente nobre de conseguir aliviar
a dor
não tinha expectativa de cura era só
controle e esse paciente ea ao meu
consultório para ser tratado como um
doente
até que um dia
eu pensei será que estou fazendo uma
coisa bacana de analgesia ar ou
anestesiar a dor
será que isso é uma solução ou uma
ilusão e quem me fez entender isso não
foi à escola não foi à universidade que
me fez entender isso foi um paciente
esses encontros especiais que mudam a
nossa história
o senhor valdemiro ele foi meu
consultório queixando de uma dor lombar
irradiada para a perna
eu não tive dúvida ele tinha uma
estenose de canal medular
eu pensei bloqueio de dor para um
bloqueio de dor e vai ficar sem dor e
foi isso que eu fiz um bloqueio de dor
ele ficou sem dor foi pra casa feliz
porém um mês depois ele retornou
queixando novamente de dor
não tive dúvida tinha dado certo o
primeiro bloqueio funcionou novamente o
bloqueio
ele me olhou gente com uma carta
indignada ficar indignado que mudou
minha vida porque virou pra mim e falou
assim doutora mas é isso que vai ser a
minha vida eu não senti dor
vou vir aqui fazer bloqueio e depois não
sente dor novamente vou fazer bloqueio
novamente
se você está querendo dizer que você não
tem cura para a minha dor
nesse momento eu fui retirada da minha
zona de conforto
parecia que eu estava fazendo nada que
até com vergonha e aí nesse momento eu
decidi que eu não ia mais me limitar a
aliviar dor ele estava firmemente
decidida a tratar dor a tornar esse
paciente dolorosos pacientes saudáveis
novamente e para isso eu preciso mudar
tudo mudar tudo inclusive na minha
formação de médica eu não era mais uma
profissional que editava por esse
paciente uma prescrição
ao contrário eu parei de tratar dor para
tratar um paciente que tinha dor e
comecei envolver-me com as suas
histórias
precisei estudar mais precisa e não me
limitar mais a uma especialidade busquem
outras especializações
eu buscava nessas especializações um
tratamento mas eu buscava um saber de
mim capacitasse para receber paciente
olhar para aquele paciente está disposta
a escutar sua história a conhecê lo
integralmente não satisfaziam mais ver
um pedaço de um sintoma
eu queria ver o paciente inteiro como
aquela dor tinha começado o que eu
poderia fazer para que ela fosse embora
e ele pudesse resgatar a sua vida
novamente trabalho escola
eu queria que o suficiente não fosse
mais dependente de medicamentos que ele
não tivesse gastar grande parte do seu
salário com medicamentos gerou dentro de
mim uma inquietude uma inquietude eu não
me conformava mais em ser uma prescritor
hora e que iria ser uma consultora em
saúde e isso foi muito interessante que
eu precisei ter uma visão além da dor e
quando eu comecei a ter ter uma visão
além da dor eu precisei quebrar
paradigmas
eu precisei buscar o meu jeito de cuidar
do paciente um jeito em que eu não era
mais importante que ele mas ele era tão
responsável quanto eu
nesse processo de construir saúde
eu descobri ao longo deste trabalho onde
o time inquietude buscar em outras
especializações porque conhecemos o
paciente me envolvi nas histórias dele
queria mudar sua rotina seu estilo de
vida
procurei fazê lo entender que os seus
atos de vidas poderiam ser ruins
tentei estimulá lo a ser sensível e
perceber o que fazia mal e o que ele
poderia fazer por ele
e nessa caminhada eu descobri uma coisa
muito interessante eu descobri que
doença não é azar saúde não é mera sorte
lução é um processo construtivo
consciente ou inconsciente e que para
tratar dor eu precisaria desconstruir a
dor construindo saúde e isso era uma
aventura muito interessante
eu me sentia muito bem com esse trabalho
meu consultório ficou muito mais rico
muito mais alegre as pessoas me
procuravam mais pra ser doentes
elas me procuravam para construir saúde
elas não iriam nome lá para eu definir
um nome de uma doença e autorizá las a
usar remédio pra sempre
elas me procuravam por que elas queriam
viver melhor e deste modo eu entendia
que eu estava diminuindo o consumo de
medicamentos que eu estava promovendo
saúde e até mesmo um planeta mais
sustentável
isso estava me deixando muito feliz com
o tempo fazendo esse trabalho eu
desenvolvi um método de tratamento de
dor a partir da construção de saúde
cuidando de cinco pilares porque eu
entendi que a dor é a ponta do iceberg
que revela pilares fragilizados e
principalmente que eu não tenho o
direito de tirar essa sensação do meu
paciente uma sensação que pode fazê-lo
curar sua história com uma criança um
bebê que chora quando ele está
precisando de algo o nosso corpo dói
quando ele está precisando que a gente
tome uma atitude e não é interessante
não é inteligente tomarmos apenas um
remédio é muito melhor tomar a atitude
e eu com pillay então estes cinco
pilares em respiração alimentação
postura pensar
pinto e som com respiração
eu preciso entregar pro meu corpo
o oxigênio de qualidade se não tiver
mais de qualidade ou se meu pulmão não
está em boa condição e eu não conseguir
entregar pra minha célula oxigênio de
qualidade eu vou descer e muitas vezes
vou ter dores que eu nem sabia que era
por isso o pilar da alimentação
bom vocês sabem de que tamanho vocês
nasceram pequenininhos e hoje vocês são
deste tamanho
vocês são o que vocês comeram beberam e
absorveram e todas as conseqüências
disso boas ou ruins
bom o pilar da postura o músculo é nosso
motor negligenciar isso vai nos trazer
muitos problemas
acho musculares e articulares e muitas
vezes as pessoas fazem até cirurgias
por que não cuidaram adequadamente diz
pilar da musculatura ea musculatura bem
condicionada ela determina coordenação
equilíbrio e força e não só nos faz ter
saúde particular
como ela define definir a nossa postura
diante da vida
o pilar do pensamento é o pilar onde o
corpo com clay sentimentos
negligenciados muitas vezes no
consultório ou muitas vezes até pelo
próprio paciente que não se autoriza
sentir
analisei sentimentos que causavam
desconforto e com pillay este sentimento
sem tristeza o sentimento do pulmão
raiva sentimento do fígado preocupação
sentimento do pâncreas medo sentimento
do rim e ansiedade sentimento do coração
e comecei a me interessar pelos
sentimentos como geradores de doença e
de dor
bom a vida estava bacana
mas ea gente aceita desafio a vida nos
desafia até que um dia o encontrei uma
paciente que foi o meu consultório e
queixando de uma dor intensa que
começava nas costas e irradiando o
coração como se fosse uma espada
essa paciente chegou no consultório após
uma romaria de vários tratamentos usando
analgésicos fortíssimos antidepressivos
ansiolíticos e já tinha até feito
bloqueio de dor
eu olhei para seus pacientes pensei ah e
agora que eu vou oferecer essa paciente
comecei a conversar com ela até que ela
me contou que essa dor tinha começado
após o team que ela teve um evento muito
infeliz na vida dela a filha dela que
tinha acabado de entrar na faculdade
tinha tido um desentendimento com o
namorado e saiu de casa para encontrá-lo
e ligou para ela dizendo mamãe te amo e
essa foi a última vez que essa mãe
escutou a vossa filha depois de sofre e
se jogou do 17º andar quando eu olhei
para essa mãe e eu não sabia o que fazer
impedida por um sentimento muito forte e
levantei me e abracei a nós ficamos
abraçadas muito tempo chorando eu
chorando ela chorando e chorar parecia
ser bom
depois de um tempo essa mãe explicou que
ela estava se sentindo louca porque ela
estava sentindo tanta saudade da filha
tanta saudade que o desejo dela era de
ir ao cemitério e tocar pelo menos
mocinho da filha
nessa hora eu não sabia o que fazer e eu
disse pra essa mãe que ela não era louca
que ela estava tendo um sentimento
totalmente autorizado totalmente
pertinente e que eu como médica não
sabia o que fazer por ela mas que ela
poderia voltar ao meu consultório
quantas vezes ela quisesse que eu
poderia abrir a sala
uma semana depois essa mãe voltou meu
consultório ela me trouxe uma foto da
filha
me disse que tinha parado de tomar todos
os medicamentos porque eles estavam me
fazendo mal mas que estranhamente a dor
estava menor nessa hora eu fiquei
pensando se em algum momento nós vamos
incluir amor no nosso arsenal
terapêutico e eu pergunto a vocês em
algum laboratório em algum lugar do
mundo nós temos remédio para essa dor
obrigado
[Aplausos]